an elite professional climbers
recovering this morning after a
terrifying fall and rescue at Yosemite
National Park
Emily Harrington was trying to scale El
Capitan which stands a towering 3200
feet she's very lucky because she
suffered only minor injuries and a mild
concussion we caught up with Harrington
and her boyfriend fellow climber Adrian
Ballinger after the fall Nikki booty
shows us her incredible fight for
survival
the worst definitely went through my
head quite a bit and I was really afraid
emily harrington knows the risks but the
five-time US sport climbing champion
slipped and fell about 40 feet while
attempting to climb yosemite s dangerous
al Capitan
with only a rope for safety hidden some
things on the way down Harrington's team
found her collapsed on a Ledge in
freezing temperatures they worked on
immobilizing her spine while trying to
keep her conscious a search-and-rescue
crew got to them within 90 minutes to
rush Harrington to the hospital it got
really scary for a while then he just
started to imagine what the rest of
lives might look like not different it
might be d'amour we've imagined the
veteran climber also credits her
climbing partner Alex Honnold for
helping rescue her in 2017 Hahnel became
the first person to climb El Capitan
without a safety rope Harrington had
free climbed the mountain in six days
back in 2015 this time she was trying to
reach its peak in less than 24 hours
just last year two experienced climbers
plunged to their deaths while scaling
elcapitan this was very very challenging
and it's really the top less than 1% of
climbers can even attempt this route
professional mountain guide John
caderousse Key says preparing for these
high risk climbs takes years the mindset
that goes into this climb the planning
that goes into this climb all the
details probably saved her life
Harrington says the fall isn't going to
stop her from trying to conquer the 3200
foot climb once again obviously climbing
is inherently dangerous and risky and we
take risks when we do it and I'm still
going to do that for CBS this morning
I'm Nicki batiste so glad emily is okay
I was just gonna say I'm glad she's okay
and doesn't sound like she's changing
her mind about trying it again boyfriend
Adrian Ballinger was here and they
always say that's dangerous they know it
I love doing I'd love to do it